foreign
[Music]
folks welcome back to our Channel
today's agenda is pretty exciting we are
venturing into the world of meditation
mobile apps and we have mid-journey by
our side for this creative Journey now
what is mid-journey you might ask it's a
fantastic tool that uses artificial
intelligence to help create unique
custom graphics it offers a refreshing
way to break free from the constraints
of stock images allowing us to infuse a
personal touch and aesthetic Beauty into
our design it's essentially an artist in
your pocket ready to generate beautiful
and unique visuals at your command
if you're excited about integrating more
AI tools into your design process we
recommend checking out our chat GPT for
ux UI design ebook that delves deeper
into how AI can be leveraged to enhance
and streamline Your Design workflow you
can find the link in the video
description let's get to work our
starting point today is figma where
we'll create three iPhone 14 frames each
of these frames represents a screen in
our meditation app the splash screen
home screen and meditation screen to
keep things organized we'll rename each
frame appropriately
next up let's gather some inspiration
have a look around Pinterest or Google
to find images or illustrations that
speak to you something along the lines
of peaceful sunsets and soft orange or
purple Hues once you've found something
you love download it we'll use these
images as a reference in the journey
alright now it's time to get started
with mid-journey if you're new to this
platform you'll need to sign up first
it's important to note that majority
currently uses Discord for account
management so you will need to have a
Discord account in case you're not
familiar with the process you can find a
detailed step-by-step article in the
description below which will guide you
on how to sign up for my journey once
you've successfully set up your majority
account it's time to start generating
upload the image you previously chose to
Mid journey by providing the image we're
essentially giving majority an idea of
the style we're after once your image is
uploaded open it right click and choose
the copy image address option paste it
into the chat and now it's time to write
our prompt you can copy the exact prompt
that I use or feel free to adjust it to
suit the results you want by default
mid-journey generates images with an
aspect ratio of one to one so if we want
to change that we need to add an aspect
ratio parameter at the end of The Prompt
to change the aspect ratio of a general
generation to three to two once you're
ready hit enter and watch mid Journey
work its magic it can take a few seconds
or sometimes minutes for Mid journey to
generate four different images based on
the profit if the images aren't quite
what you were hoping for that's all
right you can adjust your prompt for
more specificity and try generating new
images if you like one of the images you
can choose to upscale it upscaling
increases the image size simultaneously
improving the details for a smoother
look after a short wait while majority
generates the upscaled image it's ready
to download let's take our design a step
further for that we use a fantastic tool
from replicate.com called nightmare AI
this tool is a game changer it can
significantly enhance the quality of
your images to use it you might need to
sign in with your GitHub account now
upload the image we've just created
you'll see an option to adjust the scale
rewrite it to two and then hit submit
just hold on for a few seconds while
nightmare AI works on your image as soon
as the processing is done you'll see the
difference right away the image is now
sharper and higher in quality now that
we have our enhanced image it's time to
bring it into our design download the
image and insert it into the home frame
in figma
next let's repeat the process for the
meditation music screen find another
image or illustration that you like and
upload it to my journey remember to copy
the image address so the journey
understands the style we're aiming for
write a clear prompt that captures what
you want and then let mid-journey
generate the images you can continue to
iterate and upscale the images until
you're satisfied with the results once
you've got your desired image download
it and bring it over to nightmare AI for
enhancement
after nightmare AI has worked its magic
in the images downloaded it's time to
head back to figma here we'll tweak the
color of the frames using the Color
Picker tool we'll choose a color
directly from the image this ensures a
seamless transition between the image
and the background
with that done bring the new upscaled
image into the meditation frame in figma
and adjust its size to fit the frame
let's get our final image for the splash
screen for mid-journey as always upload
an image that resonates with your design
Vision to Mid journey and provide a
suitable prompt this time since we're
working on a splash screen that requires
a vertically oriented image use a two to
three aspect ratio parameter in your
prompt continue refining and upscaling
until you achieve a result you're
pleased with once you have the perfect
image don't forget to take it through
the nightmare AI
[Applause]
[Music]
then insert the final image into the
splash screen frame in the figma file
and resize it
now that we have our beautiful custom
graphics in place we can start adding
content to the screen we'll start with a
splash screen for those who might be new
to app design a splash screen is the
first screen you see when you open an
app it's typically used to showcase the
app's logo and branding while the app
loads we'll Begin by creating a name for
our meditation app
once we've got our name let's add a
short tagline beneath it a tad line is a
catchy phrase that represents the brand
message or the key feature of the app
now let's add a logo to our splash
screen you can either create a new one
or download the one we've used in the
provided figma file that you can find in
the video description
our splash screen is all set now let's
move on to designing the home screen
we'll start by copying the text from the
splash screen rewrite this text to serve
as an introduction for the home screen
foreign
next up is the creation of a search bar
that users can utilize to search for
Content within the app we'll need a
magnifying glass icon as it's a
universal symbol for search function we
can easily get a free icon from Google
Icons or hero icons
once we have it let's create an auto
layout frame and apply fill and stroke
to it this will be the basic structure
of our search bar
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we can make the elements inside the
search bar more subtle so it's clear
that this field is not currently active
and a text is only a placeholder finally
we can add a stroke to the search bar
[Music]
once we're happy with it copy the title
and change it to categories
we're going to use five different icons
to represent the categories you can find
these icons for free on Google Icons or
get them from the figma file below the
video now add an auto layout to the
first icon and set the padding to 10
pixels on all sides we'll also add
background color you can use the Color
Picker to grab a color from the search
bar to give our icon a softer look apply
an 8 pixel Corner radius now duplicate
the entire frame four times
all you have to do now is copy each
different icon right-click the existing
icon inside the frame and choose paste
to replace
[Music]
with all our icons in place select all
of them and slightly adjust their color
we want them to blend nicely with our
design and not be too vibrant
to ensure the icons are evenly spaced
add an auto layout we're going to remove
the auto layout afterwards as we still
need to add names for our categories now
let's add category names grab your text
tool and type the name for the first
category
[Music]
select the text in the icon and create
an auto layout ensuring there's four
pixel spacing between the two elements
we'll also adjust the pass-through of
the category name to 80 to keep the text
from being overly bright
foreign
for each icon creating an auto layout
between the icons and category names
with four pixel spacing after renaming
the categories you should have five
nicely arranged category icons each with
its own name
[Music]
now select all the frames and apply Auto
layout then select the entire Auto
layout and title and create another Auto
layout this time with 12 pixel spacing
now we just have one more section of the
home screen left to tackle
copy the title from before and adjust it
for this section we'll need to tap into
mid Journey's magic again to generate
three images for this part go through
the familiar process find an inspiring
image feed it to my journey create a
prompt and download the resulting image
[Music]
don't forget to upskill the image using
nightmare AI for that high quality
finish
[Music]
with your image ready bring it into your
figma file
[Music]
[Applause]
now add a couple of text layers below
the image to provide more information
about a specific mindfulness session
[Music]
following this duplicate the entire
frame and rewrite the texts for each one
go back to my journey to generate two
more images for these frames
thank you
perfect now that this is done we have
one important element left to add a
bottom navigation let's shift all the
screen elements a little upwards to make
room for our bottom navigation
for this we'll need four icons each
representing a different screen of our
app you can Source these icons from
sites such as Google Icons or hero icons
or find them directly in the figma file
below the video once you have your icons
select the second third and fourth icons
and adjust the pass-through property to
60. this signifies that the icon with
the most vibrant color is representing
the current screen that's in use now
it's just a simple matter of duplicating
the bottom navigation and moving it over
to the last screen be sure to adjust the
colors so that the second icon becomes
the active one now let's duplicate this
Frame one more time and carry it over to
the last screen adjust the text to match
a mindfulness session or meditation
music
we're about to add a little extra
interactive Flair to our design an audio
waveform visualization this visual
component will provide users with a
graphical representation of the music's
intensity as well as the progress of the
audio playback to create this let's draw
four lines of varying lengths
[Music]
once you're done group these lines
together in an auto layout this small
cluster of lines will serve as our basic
waveform unit which we can then
duplicate multiple times until we reach
a length that resembles a full audio
track
foreign
[Music]
now let's add some color to our waveform
changing the color of certain lines will
illustrate that the audio track is still
in progress
[Music]
lastly we're going to place the current
playback time at the start of our
waveform and the total length of the
audio track at the end this way users
can easily understand where they are in
their session or music track
[Music]
thank you
great work now let's add some player
controls you can Source these icons from
Google Icons or directly from the figma
file provided in the video description
feel free to adjust the color of the
controls if you wish this part is
completely up to you and your Creative
Vision
lastly we're going to add one final
touch a status bar at the top of our
screens
and our mobile app is done
if you found this tutorial helpful
subscribe to our Channel we'll be
creating more content to help you
leverage technology in your design
process
[Applause]